Sir.
Morning. Good. We'll wait for another three, four minutes.
Yes, sir. Yes, sir.
Good evening to all. Good evening, sir.
Good evening, sir. Good evening, sir.
Good evening, sir.
Good evening, and others. Good evening, sir.
Yeah,
so I, I, shall we start?
Yeah. Yes, sir. We can start. Yeah.
Um, so let
me also put here
trying to log in through my, also, just gimme a minute.
I am trying to join.
Yeah, I think I should go ahead.
Hope, uh, my screen is visible. Uh, not yet. Not shared.
No, no. Okay. Let me share the screen.
Is it visible now? Uh, it's coming up ups.
It's visible now. Yeah.
Uh, I think, uh, one thing, uh, I think this module
I requested Sunil, that I will, I will cover, that's
where we might have went ahead
with sequence to sequence model.
Uh, this is a short module.
Um, uh, see when we discussed about, uh,
recurrent neural network or gated recurrent neural network
or LSTM, uh, let go to that structure.
If I have one structure, I should like to, uh,
even if you consider this itself, see always so far,
we discuss it that, uh, the,
the information starts at the time.
T equal to zero say
and moves towards the right that is left
to right sequence only.
Okay. And say a unidirectional thing.
We have, uh, written maybe the intuition also to explain,
no, suppose, uh, if I take a written text excerpt
for our Arabic script, but most of the scripts, no,
we write from left to right.
Okay? And also when you speak,
also when you generate speech, that also evolves, uh,
with the time from time T code to zero moves forward.
Okay? Maybe that is the way, uh, since
that is the most common, uh, thought process.
That's why people, when they,
when we explained all these things, we explained about, uh,
left to right assumption of the sequence modeling,
whether it is R-N-N-L-S-T-M
or um, gated, recurrent, uh, unit GRU.
But what we did not there is an equally suppose
as humans, uh, when I do any sequence to sequence modeling,
uh, task, uh,
other possibilities are there.
That means to say, uh, one case is left to right knowledge,
which is available till that point I make use
to predict the next thing.
Or it is al already possible that no,
there is a right to left.
Information is also possible.
And more commonly, one is the bidirectional one.
Bidirectional one.
So that becomes more obvious that
suppose I'm standing in a certain position in the sequence
and I want to predict something at that point of time,
maybe say, predict the next cell state, uh, information
for the next cell state
or cell state prediction at that point of time,
or the output at that point of, at
that position in the sequence.
There are cases where I may have
to look at the knowledge on both sides
means from the beginning till
that point, from left to right.
Similarly from that position, from right till
that position from the right to left, both can be used for
no computing proper state value at that position.
And also predicting the output at that point of time. Okay?
And that is common in practice.
So that's, we know, um, uh,
the next development was in terms of, uh, coming up
with bidirectional sequence models.
Structure wise, uh, it's very straightforward.
If you have understood, um, um, uh, RNN,
maybe I have a structure here.
For example, uh, if you take RNN, uh, so far
what we discuss at is we have come this lawyer, lawyer role
is RNN cells.
Cells, okay? Starting from S zero, I will go to say SI
or the output, and I'm making use of X zero,
X one, x two, et cetera.
XI. And uh, this S3 is a cell state,
and you get the next cell date,
and the output can be predicted at this part,
you forget about the row,
which is moving from right to left.
I'm talking about left to right.
This only if I take a unidirectional sequence model is
there, RNN, where the information flow
happens from left to right.
And I can also
reverse the operation, starting from information flow,
taking from rightmost point
and move back towards the leftmost point
that is right to left.
RNN that is also in unit direction,
but the information flow happens from right to left.
Um, the, uh, when it comes to the bidirectional,
we are information available at any position,
both from right to left
or left to right, for example,
to predict the output at zero eight, position sequence,
position zero in the left to right.
I use a zero and x zero,
and, uh, whatever the cell state,
I compute poit onto the next position.
And also the cell state position is used
for predicting the correct, same way, uh,
same X zero is used,
but the cell state information is from right
to left up to that point.
I use both of them. I combine and get,
and the upper row will give me the knowledge from right
to left till that position.
Similarly, lawyer one is the knowledge from left
to right till that position
and combine them to predict the output.
Okay? And such an architecture is called as, uh, uh,
bidirectional recurrent network.
And it's variance ca can be a simple RNN cell,
or it can be a STM or it can be a gated recurrent unit.
Okay? And such a, uh, thing is called
as a bidirectional RNN.
And, uh, of course, you know, um,
especially in the NLP
and uh, those tasks, even cases speech also
in case of music processing also, we can make use of
such things extensively
to dis agate the output in any particular position.
Uh, so of course we have seen know the sequence modeling is
far dering knowledge from the sequence
for prediction classification.
You have this R-N-N-L-S-M-J designed
to look only from the sequence.
In the past many applications where future part
of sequence needs to be into are both, uh,
only future part, then it becomes right
to left RNN unit direction,
whereas both means it becomes by direction.
Of course, I, at that point of time, I did not get a, um,
a proper example.
Maybe Sunil,
if he remembers any other example he should tell,
but at that time, no, uh, I remembered
that Maha statement, no.
Um, and then he marmar,
okay, see this part?
No, that he murmured,
but he said very prominently.
And, uh, when his father, I think,
or somebody, no, father,
when he heard that, no, then he felt,
no, when his son is last, why he has to fight.
So he left his arm,
and then that, uh, position was exploited to defeat.
Okay? So that's what Tama is dead.
And then he affirm, I don't know if it is a man or elephant,
because the, remember I are told I cannot
say lie, uh, to large.
Uh, when large Krishna told, oh,
you are the most trusted person when,
when you tell like this, uh, he will believe,
but he told I cannot do that.
That's why he told there is an elephant by name,
Tama, you'll kill that.
And then you say, Tama is dead,
but then you marmar, I don't know if it's a man or elephant,
but when is not able to hear that.
So that means to say, so, uh, he, he held only this part
of the sentence from left to that point, that point.
But if he has learned the future part of the sequence also,
then he would've taken a different decision.
So that is where that, uh, now bidirectional, uh,
model concept comes into picture.
Maybe Sunil, if you have any other example you
can tell after this.
Okay? And, um, um, I just wanted
to say that this is a simple example I got,
but, uh, you can imagine your own examples where,
at any position in the sequence to take a decision at
that point of time, I would like
to look at the information available till
that point from left to right
and also from right to left, both knowledge I use
for doing Predictional classification,
and that is called as a bidirectional, uh,
sequence models, okay?
For example, in a ne neighbor entity recognition task,
if you take, uh, I, I want to ask Ashoka is a person
or place, okay?
So somebody, uh, if you go for a sentence,
Ashoka is a great warrior.
I can also say Ashoka is a good hotel.
So in the first case, it is a great warrior.
It ference to a person.
It is based around this future thinking.
Similarly, it's a place again, referring to the,
um, um, as well.
So then I will say I went to Kari and took a bath, okay?
So then I went to Kari means, you know,
at this Kari position, you will have a, uh, know
ambiguity enabled entity ion task, or whether it's a river
or, uh, a name
or a some other person name, okay?
And that only, uh, gives a dissemination gives only when,
when COVID is a personal river.
Uh, it depends on referring to both the things.
So need for looking into sequence knowledge,
both from past and future.
And that is what motivated them to, uh,
create these architectures for, uh,
bi-directional sequence models.
And that's where this architecture explained
and then went similarly, you can have LS team also observed.
There's no difference there. Basic cell will be like that.
And even you can have GRU like this. Uh, okay.
And, uh, of course, uh, the equations, if you recall,
in a forward direction, the, the cell state
at the time, TAFT, is given
by the cell state at T minus one,
and the input at time t
through the respective weight metrics, plus the bias
positive through and only near output function.
G will give me the state value at that point
in the backward direction.
If you see B of T, this is the 80 is the current time.
T minus one, I'm referring TOS state.
Whereas in BT, I refer to that the future instance,
the BT plus one rest remains safe.
The bias will be BA and,
and then the output is the function of both the A and bt.
Where a is the knowledge
computed cell state computed at Timet by using left
to right, BT is the knowledge computed from right to left,
and both are used through the right metrics
and the neural network output to get the current output.
So this is how the, in case of unidirectional,
I will have only either this left to right,
only unidirectional backward direction.
Only right to left is this one
by direction is a combination of this.
So of course you can.
Uh, so one extension is you have unidirectional,
then you get bidirectional.
And if you see this whole thing can be treated
as one layer of a deep architecture, okay?
Then you can have deep architectures based sequence model,
where essentially what will happen is I'll go
to the simple structure.
Let us consider a bidirectional RNN.
There is one layer, first layer that I apply external input
and the respective states, and then compute this output.
Now suppose for a deep, uh, version of this, RNN
by additional RNN, this is layer one,
I will have layer two ABO on top of it, the layer two for
that, this first layer output access input, okay?
And then compute the layer to output.
And accordingly, you can stack any number of layers
to get the deeper versions of the,
uh, no, uh, recurrent, which are, um,
so it'll be same thing, uh, no, uh, deep R
and deep LSMG architectures you can create, uh, where,
uh, essentially first layer you feed
with the external raw data then goes
through several layers of these.
And, uh, where you have, uh, shallow, no,
this thing we have told know, typically one or two, uh, one
or two layers, too many, many layers we are talking about,
um, in case of shallow architecture,
the hidden state information is passed on
to produce the output.
But in the deeper architecture, you have many layers.
Each, each layer is nothing.
But, uh, you know, if you take bidirectional,
it's a bidirectional architecture,
and you pass on that, uh, output to improve
as you move from one layer to the other layer, for example,
this is a deep architecture where xon X two is applied,
then this output applied to next layer, uh,
and then apply to the next layer.
Then you compare the final.
This is a typical example of a, a deep architecture,
uh, where suppose, um, you will have a one,
you will have a one T minus one xt, whereas a two,
uh, cell state A two, it depends on A one T
and a two T minus one, similarly, A-A-A-I-T
or something, a i minus one T,
and, uh, um, index of t
and a IT minus one.
So those will be added to get the deeper version of it.
So I'll just top it here if you have any, uh,
no clarifications I will provide here.
Um, any of you, if you have any,
Uh, sir, I, I have a small question.
Yeah. Uh, in that flow diagram, you said, uh,
the output of first layer will act as input
to these top layer, second glance.
Ah, correct. Is it the whole output of,
I mean panel output of first layer access input,
or at each stage, at each axis
Access, this is what you see the diagram.
Each, each, each node, yes. Access, input,
Input as well as well, the final, uh, output
of sequence one will act as input to the second layer.
No, that is not, uh, shown.
Basic architecture is this one. Okay.
See the whole output of the layer one acting as input,
that is that sequence to sequence model that we, but
unless specific deep architecture is like this respect,
you see the, the very purpose of adding more
one way is I can directly compute the output.
At this point, yes, that is what we're doing,
but that is still not mature enough.
That's where I pass it through several layers, yeah.
To get, you know, that particular stage output
and take it to the okay, only respect stages are given,
Given, okay.
Okay, sir. Thank you.
So once we have understood the basic portion of see, uh,
just to summarize, first,
we should understand the basic RNN
functioning in that vanilla model.
Then how the cell structure changes when you move to LSTM
and GRU, that is the next part,
then the whole functioning that is happening.
Then once we understand that left to right sequence model,
then we understand the bidirectional.
Once you understand the bidirectional, then you stack them
to get the D portion of this.
But otherwise, if you have a code to, uh,
do one from left to right process, the same code can be used
for right to left, and the, then you put them together
to make it a bi-directional, then you put them stacks of
that to get the deep portion of the tool.
So that is what we can do it as a part of that tool.
So I have one question. Yeah.
Uh, so in, in, in what kind of task this is unsuitable,
uh, bidirectional iron.
Ah, so of course, you know, i, I am not, uh,
I am not getting an example to the top of my mind.
Um, I can only give a general answer,
uh, no saying that, uh, uh,
suppose, um, uh, there are tasks where
the information evolution happens only from left to right,
say, okay, at any point of time when I am doing a prediction
or classification at that position,
it always requires a knowledge from, from left to right.
Then this bidirectional will not be of much useful.
Uh, I can take an example from speech.
Suppose in case of speech, if I want to, you know,
predict a particular output at any position,
always in case of speech, the signal evolves from left
to right means time t equal to zero.
It goes, even if you put a bidirectional model there, model
that life to ref model will not learn any parameters
because there are no instances coming there.
Speech technology is a very classical example
where I don't require a bidirectional model.
Understood, sir. Okay.
Thank you, Sunil.
Yes. Thank you.
Uh, of all, uh,
I'll just extend on the question what Brenda was asking,
where it is unsuitable,
and, uh, as sir mentioning that wherever you see that
future things which you have to predict is not available,
because see in the bi direction what happened, that you have
to go from left to right, right to left, both.
But if any task where the future things is not available,
for example, language modeling in just for the
simple case language models where you always have
to predict the next word.
Suppose next word is not available,
then you can't go from right to l uh, uh, right to left.
Okay? A sim, uh, one, one of the examples.
So wherever you see there is a, uh,
next word prediction task you are doing.
Maybe the bi direction is not suitable for such cases
because that is not available at all.
Then how will you process it?
So you can't train the model at the, uh, uh, that,
uh, at the test time.
It'll be anywhere not available. So it is difficult.
So that is one thing. Second thing is, uh,
then where it is suitable, I mean, it's a language model.
Suppose if I say it is not suitable, you, when you will,
will go to the transformer architecture.
Maybe in the next course you'll see that
transformer architecture, encoder decoder people have
later on separated it encoder actually, they,
they extended the encoder part to the bidirectional encoder.
Uh, that's why it is known
as Bert bidirectional encoder representation
of the transformer and decoder part.
It is a language model, so large language model,
that is how it has evolved.
So usually this bidirectional things is suitable
when the context lies in between somewhere.
Or you just imagine a sentence where the, you have
to do the fill in the blanks
and fill in the blanks is somewhere in the between, so that,
that fill in the blanks where the blank is in between.
For that, having the context of left side to
that blank in the blanks
and right side to that is very important.
Uh, that's why in such cases, the bidirectional is,
is, uh, very much helpful.
But when, if you are very certain that I have
to do the next word prediction, given the previous word,
then it is not required at all, and then it is not suitable.
So that, uh, that's why the bird do, doesn't give you,
the bird is not known for the language model.
We say it is a mask language model for these tasks
where the fill in the blanks can come anywhere in the
sentence, right?
And, uh, uh, decoder, part
of the transformer will learn about that.
It is known as the large language mental,
where we always do the expert prediction.
Okay? This is just one example.
Now, uh, uh, the example
for this bidirectional, I was just checking.
It can be, I was just seeing that it,
suppose we have a example.
Like, uh, I went, uh, I, I I went to the bank
to deposit money.
Suppose now, uh,
this suppose I'm processing only from left to right.
So first I'll process, I then I'll process rent, then
to then the,
and then bank when I'm processing bank, uh, it,
it is, it is not clear.
It is, um, um, ambiguous
that whether this bank is representing the financial bank
or the river bank, but the next word, next few word,
which is saying that to deposit money, right now,
it is making very clear that this bank,
which is coming in this particular sentence,
is about the financial bank.
So suppose by the time I'm, I'm processing bank,
if one context is coming from right
to left about deposit money, then that bank word at the time
of word, when, when at the, at the time of processing
that word bank, there is no ambiguity.
So in such cases, it is, it is quite helpful when the, uh,
context comes from, um, both the site.
Okay. So yeah, this was just an example I wanted to give.
If you have any further query, you can ask.
Otherwise, I'll share my screen now,
Uh, understood. So
I have one more question. Yes.
So we know that RN suffer from, uh, vanishing
and exporting grads, right?
So will there be any impact on, uh, bidirectional RNs?
Like will it suffer more or less or how?
See, the, the, the, we know that, uh, r
and n the way it suffers from the vening gradient problem,
it'll be true even for the bidirectional, okay?
Uh, and that is what we try to, uh, overcome
with L-S-T-M-G-R-U where this effect will be minimal, right?
So the, the concept itself of the vanishing gradient in the,
and then still persist,
although you have the, uh, the, uh,
because it, it depends on the sequence length, not, uh,
because we are doing the processing from both the end,
as the sequence length will grow,
there will be high chances in the RNN
to have this van in gradient problem.
Okay? The length is a problem. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
Okay. Okay. So let me share my screen. Now,
In the example you said, mm-hmm.
Uh, I went to the bank. Mm-hmm.
Uh, what if the complete information is processed
from left to right?
Uh, okay. I went to the bank to deposit money.
Uh, so from the, from the left to right,
when I am processing this information, at least some
of the clarity, what I have got is this bank,
which I was talking about, it is about the financial bank.
That is what is the information when you're processing from
left to right, you are getting right, even to deposit,
that will also come okay?
But at the later part of the time.
But when you are processing the word bank itself,
that information was not clear.
But that will also get clear.
It'll be more clear if you are
processing it from right to left.
Okay? Okay. Okay. So that is how it's Got it, yeah.
Okay.
Okay. So just to recap that, what we did in the previous,
uh, class that I started with the sequence
to sequence modeling, first of all,
I gave you the motivation that where it is required, okay?
So we said that, okay, we have already learned about how
to process the sequences, and now we are very clear that
whenever there is a sequential data, R-N-N-L-S-T-M-G-R-U,
these are the models which we should
start with always, right?
And we should not, I mean, although you can do,
but C-N-N-A-N-N may not, uh, uh, may not, uh,
do a good job with the sequential data.
So, uh, so,
but the problem with the rium, the kind
of the network, what we have, uh, learned so far, we, we saw
that the r
and n we have learned mostly as a many to one
or one to one, many to one, one to one.
You, you remember, we, I talked about many types
of the networks, which are possible.
So many to one. I said one, then many to many. I said, okay.
So, uh, one to many also, I said, where we, I, we,
we talked about the image captioning example.
You feed one image as a data and get caption number of words
or tokens as an output.
So we have talked about these settings,
but this, this, uh, uh, uh, setting of sequence
to sequence modeling, we had not talked much.
Now, why it is important to learn about this sequence
to sequence modeling separately,
because see, architecture wise
or the, uh, the neuro architecture wise,
we are still using LSTM or RNN, okay?
There is now no change.
The way the LSTM we have, uh, learned so far,
same thing we are going to use here.
Only thing is it is explicitly, I'm telling
that you process this LSTM network.
In fact, you have to process two different LSTM
networks, right?
So one network will act like a encoder.
Another, a network will act like a decoder.
Now, why it is important, why it was important,
because the sequence, which we have learned so far,
and which we have handled so far, it was only at the input
of these LSTM network.
And we have handled it.
We, we, we already talked about it, that how
to handle this variable length of sequence,
which are possible in your input, okay?
So because now we are processing as a time stamp,
we can process whatever length of the sequence we have
for every input, right?
So those things we have, we discussed,
but the problem here came
because now my output sequence is also of variable length.
And this output sequence length doesn't rely on your
input sequence length.
It's not like it is one-to-one that for every input here,
I have an output here.
If that is the case, then again, it is very simple.
Whatever we have learned so far, we could have done it.
For example, suppose for I, there is a, uh, translation, M
and for M, there is a translation there.
Foregoing, there is a translation. Raha.
Now see if this is fixed, that
for every English word I have one Hindi word
as an output, then there is no problem.
Whatever we have learned, I think
that would've been sufficient.
But the problem here is
that my input sequence length will be different,
and my output length, corresponding output sequence length,
the target language length would be different.
So if, suppose I have three times stamp here in this lstm,
I may not get four words out of it,
because every, uh, every word,
every output will give me a single output.
And hence, having a single STM network will not work.
So we need to have two different network, first of all,
and that's why this encoder decoded architecture, uh, uh,
which says that, okay, first of all, you process your input,
get the context vector, okay?
And from this context vector, you try to, you try
to start generating the, uh, the output sequence
of whatever language you wish to do.
And that's where the sequence to sequence modeling, uh,
is, is it is different.
Uh, it is using the LSTM or RNN uh, uh, knowledge.
But then the architecture wise,
there are two different arch, uh,
two different LSTM network.
You can see here, one is known as the encoder network.
Another one is known as the decoded network.
And in between we have this context vector. Okay?
So this is what we have talked about.
And used cases either can be machine translation,
summarization, question answering,
all these things we had talked about.
And then I had, uh, I had shown you that, okay,
suppose machine translation is a use case.
Then how to, how to train the sequence to sequence model
and how to, uh, do the inferencing or the testing.
So what we did, as usual for any text data,
we start with the tokenization.
So we did the tokenization separately for the Hindi corpus,
the input and the eng English, uh, sorry, English corpus,
the input and the Hindi corpus, the output.
Okay? And we created two different
vocabulary out of it, okay?
Hindi vocabulary and English vocabulary.
So all, and here,
these two vocabulary are completely different, right?
So you can see that the index number, um, index number for,
for the English word is same for the Hindi word for some
of the word, but then these tokens are different,
and they're not going to, they're going to feed,
we are going to feed these vocabulary to the model
separately at the encoded time or decoded time.
So there won't be any conflict for the model itself.
Then when the model will see one, whether it should treat it
as math, or it should treat it as I, okay,
that model doesn't have to confuse with,
because at the encoder time,
you will only feed English vocabulary.
In the decoder time, you'll only feed the Hindi vocabulary.
So there won't be any confusion for the model.
And hence, uh, we first converted the vocabulary into the
one hot vector, and then we started doing the training.
At the training time, we talked about
the teacher forcing method.
See, it is not compulsory to have the teacher forcing,
but it is always good to have the teacher forcing, right?
Why? Because at the training time, there is a high chance
that the decoder will do the mistakes,
because yet it is still training, okay?
When you have started the training, there's a high chance
that what it'll generate will not be what you want
as an output for this particular sentence.
For example, I am going
and it is giving as my mu raha, Ja,
which is not a correct translation for this sentence,
I am going, right?
So just, just to, just to have a better understanding
for this decoder network, what we did anyway, we have the
parallel corpus available for this sentence.
I'm going, let us feed that correct word at each time,
time stamp in the decoder, ma, it is a correct sequence in,
uh, of this particular sentence.
I'm going, so irrespective of what we are getting,
the output here will feed what is the correct,
which is available in our corpus or dataset.
Okay? So how it'll help, how it'll help.
You can say that, okay, we are being biased,
that my model is not predicting correct,
but it's still, I'm feeding, uh, man.
So, uh, I mean, this is not good.
Let the model learn by its own, which is correct. Okay?
So I, I,
that's why I said the structure forcing is just an optional.
You can always make a network in such a way
that it'll learn always from what it getting here, okay?
Because that is very important. That is very important.
But if you will do the teacher forcing,
and if you don't do the teacher forcing, in fact,
you can try with both the method and see that.
You will find that by do doing this teacher forcing,
what will happen, you can converge a little faster, okay?
Because you know, at least you're feeding the correct input.
Okay? And then for this correct input,
what is the next word prediction you want?
So this pair you have in your corpus, okay?
You have this pair you have in your corpus,
and you are at least utilizing the corpus knowledge that
what will happen is the next word, prediction task.
You can recall, right?
Self supervised learning, what we have talked about.
So Hindi corpus,
you'll always create a self supervised learning task.
So every word will act as an output for the previous word.
So for, uh, like, uh, here you can see that, right?
For Ja, the MA is an input for raha.
Maja is an input for who Maha is input, right?
So we have, we can create the data set like that.
If we can create the data set like that, why not to leverage
that one for the training,
and that's why this teacher forcing
and it'll help us to converge it faster.
Otherwise, what will happen if, suppose who is the output?
And if I'll feed the, uh, uh, this who here,
which is the wrong input,
and, uh, for who, uh, what we are, what we are supposed
to get the output, right?
But that we don't have in the ground truth,
and hence that, then,
then we will be lost in the training time.
We will be lost. Okay?
So the, that's why the reason, uh, that's why this reason,
the reason is that why we are applying the teacher
for at the training time.
So, um, yeah, so this is the, this, this is
what happened at the training time.
And then obviously as we do for any neural network,
once we process our input, we calculate the loss.
So we have the loss coming from each of these timestamp,
then we add all of those laws,
and then we start the back propagation.
Back propagation happens in the same way,
what we have discussed in the case of RNN, okay?
So that once the training is done, then there is a time
for the inferencing.
Now at the inferencing, now
as your panel corpus is not available, you have the input
and you don't have the output, right?
And that model has to predict,
the output means the corresponding, uh,
sentence in the another language.
So in that case, you can't do this
because anyway, that is not available with you.
That whatever is the right sequence that is not available
with you, hence, you have to rely on the model itself,
whatever it is predicting that you have
to feed at the next time step.
So this is what we do,
and at the inference time, which works like a
auto re auto aggressive way or next prediction task.
So this is what we discussed first,
and then I was just talking about how to enhance this, uh,
sequence to sequence model, right?
So one way of enhancing the performance would be
to introduce the embedding layer, okay?
We have talked a lot about the embedding layer, even in the,
in the hands-on, I have shown you many times how
to introduce the embedding layer and how does it help?
Because your input is completely one hot vector.
It is always good to have the, uh, the dense vector
as a representation of your input.
So this embedding layer is just, uh, the way
of transforming your input from the high dimensional sparse
vector into low dimensional dense vector.
And those low dimensional dense vector will go
as an input to the encoder.
First, get the context vector even in the decoder.
First you convert them into the low dimensional dense vector
and then process it, okay?
So this will improve your, uh, performance,
because now the,
the LSTM is seeing a little better representation
of the input, right?
So it'll improve a little bit performance.
And sometimes we also just know was explaining, right?
So you can have the deep network, right
where I was talking, right?
In the a NN you may have the multiple hidden layers, right?
But in the lstm, we have been seeing that, okay,
only one LSTM layers we have kept,
but you can always keep the two layers of the lstm,
three layers of the lstm, likewise, okay?
And the idea is that just to get some,
some more inherent pattern or meanings
or the context from the sentence,
and maybe each layer will be capturing one of them so
that it'll help altogether, the entire network to uh, uh,
give the translation or whatever sequence
to sequence task you're doing in a better way.
So yeah, this is what we have, uh, talked about.
And at last I was talking about that, okay?
Uh, when this, this sequence
to sequence model may fail, right?
So I had given you the example that when,
take the example up again, machine translation,
and you have given the whole paragraph
as in input for this encoder.
So first of all, this, say that 50 words
or a hundred words, whatever it has in the,
in this paragraph, it'll get processed at the decoder site
first, and then it'll give you one context vector.
Now, the problem
with this context vector is it has a huge responsibility
that it has to remember all the a hundred words in
some way, right?
Because, because it is L-S-T-M-I don't claim also
that it'll forget LS TM
or GRU is meant to remember the longer context,
but at the same time, uh, and it'll remember also somehow,
but the problem would be
because it, it has another responsibility that for each
of the word, what it has seen in the encoder,
there will be a corresponding, uh, some, some word
or phrases, what it has to generate at the decoder part.
No, that is the problem. That is the real problem. Okay?
So encoder site, the problem is long input
sentence must be summarized into one vector, okay?
So early words, late words will compete
for the representation and important
details may be forgotten.
That is, there is a possibility of that
because you have some limited size vector,
say five 12 dimension, 1 0 2 4 dimension.
And in this 1 0 2 4 dimension, you have
to remember breathing what you have processed here.
Okay? Now, Dakota side problem is that okay,
maybe the context vector is coming good, maybe because, uh,
because the C-L-S-T-M, it has, remember the 50 words, right?
But the problem with the decoder is the same context vector
is being fed at each time.
S stem with little variations, obviously
because you are processing something at each LSTM cell.
But this is a memory cell ct.
The upper line of the LSTM, which is traveling, right?
By being something added, by being something, uh, deleted,
all those things are possible, but the same context vector
with some variance are being fit at every
time, a stamp of the ticketer.
And that itself is creating a problem. Why?
Because if I have to get the output as meh,
I don't need the entire context vector.
I just have to know the word I so
that I could have given the word meh.
If I have to give the output a job, I don't need I
and m in that case, I just need the word go or going.
Okay? So, so if it would have been better at each time stamp
of the decoder, if I will get only
few word in the encoder, which are important,
but I'm getting everything right, and that's the problem.
So same context vector is used at every,
every decoding step.
Decoder cannot focus on the relevant source word
or encoder word leads to incorrect genic translation.
So this is what we have talked about, the limitations
of the sequence to sequence modeling
and uh, to, to, uh, just address this limitation
that we have, the attention
architecture, which we'll see later.
So, uh, this was the overall performance which was reported
that, okay, if your sentence length will, uh, start going,
uh, I guess, uh, from more than 20, uh,
I don't know whether this is a correct figure
or not, then performance was decreasing,
but I think it was per sequence
to sequence model or RN model.
I don't remember. I'll see that one, right?
So this is what we have discussed so far.
Now, if you have any query in this, whatever we have Ed,
with respect to sequence to sequence modeling, you can ask
and then we'll go for this demo.
Sure, yeah.
When we are, uh, using multiple layers, uh,
with multiple contact vector, so input is same,
then contact vector will all the contact vector will having
in the same meeting.
Uh, actually not. Why?
Because see, uh, there are multiple weights
which are coming in between.
See, uh, the context factor, what you're getting,
you can understand,
but this layer is also connected with this layer
and how they're connected.
Again, they're connected with some, uh, some weight.
Now, whatever output you're getting here
that will get multiplied with these weights.
And hence here, what you will get is not
same as what you're getting here.
And this is true for this time stamp, also this time stamp.
So hence, it is true for context factor also
because multiple weights are coming in between.
And so even for the same input,
we are getting the different context vectors
because more number
of multiplications happen, additions happen.
So obviously context vector will also
change accordingly. Yeah.
Yes. Yeah. Thank you sir. Yeah,
So one quick question, right?
So the teacher forcing as well as, um, we also have a error,
the loss based backward propagation, right?
So we, we use the same sentence at, at both places.
When you do loss calculation, it is not based on the word
by word difference or
While doing the loss calculation here,
we actually calculate the loss based on the, uh,
target sequence.
But based on the target means I don't, uh,
calculate the loss based on the input.
Doesn't have any rule, means I am
going, doesn't have any rule.
So what I'm saying is, ma, this is my label,
whether I'm getting the same thing here
or not, that is what I require.
May, uh, here, so here I first, I should get mad, then ja,
then raha, then who, if that is not the case,
then my loss is completely depending on this.
What is the output? What I'm getting here?
Uh, okay, so we use the same label at two places.
Uh, that's what you're saying, right?
Same, same label. Because in the, in the corpus
or data set, I have the correct sequence available.
I'm going measure around that is available in my data. So
That, that's our label, right? For the That's
That's your label. That's your label.
Yeah, that's your label.
But we also use the same label for teacher forcing for,
uh, for foster.
Yeah. Yeah. So see teacher forcing it.
Why I say teacher forcing because, uh, just, just
because next word is, uh, available with you, right?
Because, uh, ma how,
because this, this whole decoder acts like
a auto aggressive, right?
So it has to work, act like a auto aggressive,
that it'll give the one word
and then that word will go as an input
and will give the next word as a, uh, prediction.
So it has to work as auto aggressive,
but at the training time, why it happen, that
whatever is the next word that is available with me,
because that is there in my label,
that is there in my label.
So I'm making it compulsory, like forcing, okay,
you use this, this input
because I know that what is going
to come at the next time stamp, what is the correct word
as the next time stamp that I know.
So that is how it is, yeah.
Okay. The last calculation is the final label comparison.
Uh, but this, um, uh, teacher forcing is a time step level,
Correct? Correct. Corrections.
Correct.
Okay, thanks.
So teacher forcing is only for training period,
Right, sir? Training period.
Only for training period. Yes. Yeah. Thank
You.
Okay. Alright,
so now let us dive into the demo part.
First of all, this dataset link, I think, uh,
I have given the drive link so
that you can access it directly,
but you can always go to the Kaggle
and look for this data,
Uh, machine translation.
You can write, uh, English,
English to ndi
empty dataset, okay?
And
yeah, so I guess this is the
data or this is the data.
Maybe not this one. I get this one.
So this is the, uh, you can also have the access
of this data and you can download this English
to Hindi machine translation data.
I believe this is the data.
No, this is not, I guess
because here the sentences are too long,
multiple data sets are available.
This one's
uh, maybe this data set is okay.
Anyway, I have made it available to you.
You can look for some of the data set also doesn't matter.
Okay, so now next I will just walk through this code,
uh, where it was,
okay, this one.
So what I will do is I will show you some of the things,
everything, uh, I will not, I will not show you the training
because it'll take more time,
but I will show you some other pre-processing it steps,
which are, which is important to know.
So my dataset name is new data, do csv, I'll just upload it.
The size is small.
So new data, I will,
I'll, um, open.
So yeah, it is being uploaded.
Meanwhile, uh, I'll just run some other things.
Okay? So let me just run this
and, uh,
it is being included anyway.
So first I will, once it'll upload, I'll show you.
So first I'll run this data.
And this data, I have only two columns.
First column is simply the index,
second column in the English sentence,
third column in the Hindi sentence.
So this is what I was showing you.
So at the encoder side,
I will process the English completely.
I'll get the context vector at the decoder side,
what I will do is I'll create the self supervised data.
For example, the first word is raj, so
that will be the first word.
And for that one, the next word would be K.
So this k will be the output for this. Okay?
And then K, the next word would be pass.
And likewise, you can now understand, right?
So let me run this.
Okay, so this is the data what I have.
So, uh, uh, some
of the pre-processing is required
because in some places in the dataset you will see that, uh,
it has, if you don't drop some of the uh, uh,
rows where there is nothing, which is for example,
just imagine that in the second row there is nothing,
which is this row,
this particular column is empty, not a number, right?
In such cases it'll give you the error.
So what I'm doing here is I'm simply, uh, uh, dropping
all those rows where there is any missing values
and I'm resetting my, uh, indexes.
One second once again so that those rows will be dropped.
And I have reset my index numbers.
So you will see the only few, two rows I have seen one lag,
77,006, not six.
Here you have one lag, 77,006, not four, okay?
There are only two such rows.
If you don't do, then you'll get there.
So, uh, then what I'm doing is I'm,
I'm selecting some random samples of 10,000, okay?
There are one like 77,000 rows are there
randomly selecting 10,000.
Just because I wanted to process it.
It was not being processed.
If I was, if when I was processing the complete one,
like 77,000 rows,
and if you remember I was giving you the, uh,
why it is not processing,
I'll tell you like later at the last maybe let me first, uh,
show you the rest of the thing.
So then what I'm doing is I'm converting both the column.
So English sentence is one of the column,
another column name is Hindi sentence,
right from the data frame df.
So I'm just converting them into the list type. Okay?
First of all, uh, the string and to the list type. Why?
Because it is possible you will see
that there are some tokens which are not, uh, uh, text.
And it is like some numbers are coming in between,
some other characters are coming in between, right?
So first of all, uh, converting this data frame
as a string and then converting them into the list
type, okay?
Because later on we will be able to tokenize it as a string.
Everything will be the string when you will
tokenize it, okay?
So you can also see that what is, uh,
the output which is coming from here, for example.
Now, if you wish to see this, uh,
this is how it is, okay?
You can see this, everything,
what you've had in the one column,
now it is coming as a list.
So you can see that it is now kept
inside a particular list,
It is starting with a list
and it'll terminate with the list.
Similarly, for NDI sentence also, every row
is now it has come inside a list.
So you can see that the it is,
it is also ending with the list.
Alright? So I'll just delete that.
Now, once we have everything as a list,
now we'll start our pre-processing, the actual reprocessing.
Earlier it was a cleaning operation.
When I said here that I have dropped some of the row,
because in those roles there was missing values.
Like there is no sentences, Hindi or English sentences.
So that there, I was just dropping those row.
So that was called as data cleaning approach, right?
But now I'm doing data, pre-processing
of pre-processing in the sense that making the data
to be readable by the machines.
Now, right now it is not readable by the machine
because it is in the form of English, right?
So now I will start doing that one.
So first of all, we'll start with the tokenization so
that every token would be separated.
Then I'll count the, uh, what is the vocabulary, uh,
by assigning the unique index number
to each tokens in my English as well as NDI corpus.
So two different vocabulary I'll create
for these two different corpus.
Okay? All those things we'll do.
So to start with here, you can see
that I have some special token pat token,
unknown token start of the sentence token, end
of the sentence token, which is required
for the decoder part.
So in the decoder, you always start
with the SOS means the start of the sentence,
and you end with the end of sentence.
And these two are the extra tokens in your, in your decoder.
Because at the first time stamp,
which you can say the zeroth timestamp, you have, uh,
you have nothing to, uh, uh, uh, to generate
because nothing has been generated so far.
Okay? So you simply to initiate the process,
to generate the first word
or first token, you start as a SOS token, right?
Similarly, how the decoded will get to know that.
Here I have to stop. So you have the ES token,
and this also, uh, this with the when
after four to four timestamp, I have to give us
as a next token, or
after 40 word, I have to give the us as a next word token.
Everything the model learns, okay?
Everything is a learning, right?
So these are the four tokens with which we start called
as a special tokens.
And then this is the, uh, tokenization function
where we take the sentence,
and if not, each sentence means,
suppose your sentence is not a string, okay?
You will simply return,
you will return the empty list for that.
If your sentence is just, uh,
if your sentence is a string, right?
Then first of all, you will lower that one.
'cause you don't want to make any, uh,
problem for your token.
I, that word is starting with a capital letter.
A small letter should be treated differently.
So lower then you will strip and then you will split.
So these three are the functions.
One by one it'll be got, okay?
So at the end of it, what you will get is
that suppose this is a sentence,
politicians will be separated, do will be separated,
not will be separated, and so on.
So, uh, this is the tokenization function.
And now we'll call this function.
Now we are building here vocabulary.
And the vocabulary will be built separately for the Hindi,
separately for the English, okay?
Because you're doing the machine translation task.
So two different vocabulary you will build.
So as usual, what you do at the time of vocabulary building,
you pass the sentence, okay?
And then, um, here you can see that, right?
You're calling the tokenize this particular function which
you have defined up, okay?
You get the tokens
and then you simply counter that, uh, uh,
counter you are okay, how many times
that token has appeared, right?
And then you are building the vocabulary,
then you're building the vocabulary.
So for building the vocabulary, you simply check this logic,
uh, is seeing what we have learned earlier.
If, if it is available in the special token,
then it assign it as it is, if not available in the token,
then whatever is the size of the vocabulary,
like in the vocabulary, initially the size will be four
because in the special token you have four token.
So whatever new token will come,
it'll get the index number five.
Or if you're starting with zero, the index number four
and the next part will get the index number five and so on.
Okay? And that is what this whole code is.
We have seen this code earlier also, right?
So that, that, so this whole code is
to build the vocabulary.
Now just a function we have, uh, written
and now we are calling this function to build vocabulary,
build vocabulary for English sentence and Hindi sentence.
Now, once you will run all these, okay, let me run all these
through so that I can show you ly what is the output?
So this one, this one done this one.
And now you can see that in the English V vocabulary
we have 22,000 words.
In the Hindi V vocabulary, we have only 24,000 words. Okay?
This is how it's so 2,224 column.
So in the vocabulary, little higher
than the English vocabulary.
Now vocabulary is created.
Now we need to encode the sentences as a sequence of to, uh,
sorry, er index sequence of index.
So how do you do that?
First of all, you will get the sentence
and you will also give that vocabulary.
Suppose you're doing what for English,
you will give the English vocabulary.
If you're doing it for Hindi,
you will do the Hindi vocabulary, okay?
So you will call the tokenized function once again,
and what you will return, you will return the sequences,
uh, sequence of indices.
How will you return the sequences?
You will, you will check your vocabulary and you will fetch
or get that particular token.
And whatever is its index vocab of
that particular token vocab of that particular token.
For token in tokens, you represent you,
you simply return the token.
That is, that is the index number of that token.
Otherwise the unknown token.
So that is what is this particular function is,
and this we will do for English also in India,
also in Hindi, you will see slight difference.
There is extra line here, what is written here, okay?
Because every sentence in Hindi should start
with the SOSA start of the sentence token
and end with the end of the sentence token,
before creating the sequence of Indic indices, I, uh,
we add this one, whatever tokens you have in between,
that is okay, but you start with the S os
and with the us okay?
That is what is, you can see the one line change from this
English rest, everything is same.
That's all. Now we can call this encoded sentence, okay?
Encoded sentence or encoded Hindi sentence.
These two are the function.
We can, uh, uh, we can just,
uh, call that one.
And hence your, your sequence of the tokens are created.
You can see that one. In fact, if I want to see
that, let me see.
Oh, here it is shown also.
Okay, let me just go down and show you.
Okay, so here you just see that, uh, uh,
here you can see that, right?
So I'm just printing the English sentence zero one and, uh,
after encoded how the sentence will look like similarly
for NDI sentence, the first sentence, the zero index, and
after encoded how that sentence will look like.
And this is how it is. So this is how it is, right?
This is the first sentence, the wall level of the form,
the is actually given as the index number four wall is given
as the index number five and so on.
Similarly, who per k dard and so on.
You can see that, right? And
likewise, you can check for anything like for 10
10th sentence, but like in his notice,
the member is required to specify,
and that for, in that means that the uh, uh, word is, uh,
an index is 97 for his 1 37 and so on.
Okay? So this is how you can see that.
Now, once you have, get the sequence of the indices, okay,
now machine can understand that, right?
But the problem is that I have to do the padding,
and we have talked about it while processing the
L-S-T-M-I have explained about it.
Uh, why, because I want to process the input
as a batch padding is only required if you
process the input as a batch.
Suppose you don't want to process the input as a batch.
You want to process each row separately to the model.
That is okay? Okay? That is okay.
Then you, the, the, this padding
step is not required at all.
If suppose you want to process say
that five sentence together
or just to do the training a little faster so that instead
of calculating the five time loss,
doing the five time back propagation,
let me calculate a single loss out of this five sentence
and do only one time back propagation.
It'll save a lot of time.
So you may say that, okay, no,
but it'll impact the overall performance
true for the smaller data.
But when you have data in LAX altogether,
maybe this batching will faster your training process
as well as it may not impact on the overall performance.
Of the model also, right?
That's why we prefer
to have the batch when your data is too huge, okay?
Like one lack 77,000 or two hu two HUS data, right?
So here it is shown at the batch method.
So we have seen this earlier also, how to do the batching.
So here, the problem with the batching is that, uh, uh,
I first started, uh, doing the batching
with the maximum length of a sequence in the entire English
and the Hindi corpus.
But I was not able to process it.
I was not able to process it.
So I just, uh, uh, minimized it.
So this is the function for creating this,
this padding, okay?
And padding very simple.
You take all the sequences, find what is the maximum length,
what is the pad index you need, okay?
And then simply add all the zeros, those mini zeros.
So for example, if the length
of the sequence is greater than equal to max length, okay,
then you have to fetch everything from zero
to the max length because you can't pad anything.
You can't add any zero because, uh, length
of sequences greater than equal to the, uh, max length.
Fine. Now,
otherwise, what we have to do is we have
to take the sequence and we have to add how many zeros.
The zeros will be max length minus length of the sequence,
max length manner support max length opposite, uh, uh,
minus length of a sequence.
So length of a sequence is 10,
maximum length is coming a hundred.
So a hundred minus and 90, 90 pad,
whatever Id we'll use that we have to zero.
So 90 zeros I have to add with the sequence length.
So that is the function. But here,
what I have done is I have actually calculated
what are the maximum English sentence length in
that entire corpus one 70, maximum in the length of two 80.
So what I did, I have, uh, not used this
because it was then I was not able to process
the translation part, or not able to run the model.
So I have taken here only as a demo,
maximum English length is 20, maximum in length is 20.
So what will happen if any sentence will have more than 20
word, it'll simply discard that one.
If any sentence will have less than 20 word,
it'll add those mini zeros to it.
Okay? So that is how the padding is
working in this particular case.
And you can see here, you can see here, so my actual
sentence is this, this entire thing, you can see
that how long it is, right?
But then, because I fixed it to 20, it'll terminate
after the 20 token after 17, it is not taking any of these.
Okay? Here, the mo length of the sequence is more than 20.
So it is discarding everything after 20. Okay?
Now, if I will randomly write 10, okay?
Uh, just to showcase you 10
and 10, so, uh, here,
here it is still more than 1 48.
So it was 21. So one, one of the word was being discarded.
But you understand, right?
So, uh, you can, you can keep anything like that
and just check randomly if you will check.
Maybe one sentence would be something like
where the length is not 20.
So I'll check with one more.
Uh, here you can see that, right?
My sentence length is not 20.
So what it has done, it has added few zeros into,
so every time we are making it 20.
Okay? So this is what is the padding?
Once padding is done, then we first convert our
padded English or padded Hindi sequences,
or when I say sequences, now it is a sequence
of indices, okay?
Into the tensors, because anyway, we have
to use the PyTorch model, which only accept the tensors
as a, as an input.
So this is the tensor.
So now you can see that my tensor shape is 10,000
rows, 20 dimensional features.
Every row is represented at 20 dimensional feature. Okay?
So, uh, that is how it is. So why 20?
Because length of the, uh, sequence length is 20.
So that is how, it's why 10,000?
Because initially I have sampled only 10,000 sentence out
out of one, like 77,000 fine.
That's all. Now till this,
we were doing only pre-processing.
Now the actual things start.
Now, when we start the actual, uh, uh, modeling part, first
of all, we have to create the dataset class as usual,
the constructor, the length, and get item.
Okay? This, you all of, you know that quite well.
And then creating an instance
of this particular class means object, right?
And then creating the dataset loader class.
Now in the dataset loader class, we have to define
what will be the best size Here.
I'm taking very small best size because
otherwise it'll go to the auto of memory error.
Why? It'll go to the auto memory error I
was explaining other day.
Uh, let me just explain.
Yeah, so why it'll go to the autopsy memory error
because here, uh, just, just just take this particular case
where I have, I'm processing here.
I'm say that I'm processing here, I'm processing 32,
uh, inputs together, 32 input together.
See, encoder, there won't be any problem.
But decoder, what we have
to do is we have to calculate the loss.
Now, when we'll calculate the loss once we'll ca once we'll
have the entire sequence processed.
So I will first process the first time stem, first word,
first token, that is start.
And it suppose that word, whatever word I'm getting output,
I'll store, okay?
And I'll also store the loss,
which is coming from this particular word here.
Similarly, from this particular word, this particular word,
this particular word, this particular word.
So these outputs and their losses are being stored, okay?
And then I'll calculate the overall loss, the total loss.
See this, this particular total loss.
So what is happening is if, suppose ba size is 32.
So 32 for each of the word here means 32 words here,
32 outputs here means 32, 32 loss here also.
So here, also 32 loss here, also 32 loss here, also 32 loss.
So this is a tensor.
When I say, because this is nothing but the output.
When you, when I say you are storing, you're storing
the tensor tensor of what is the dimension of it?
It depends on what is your embedding dimension.
Here it is eight. That means
that eight dimensional dimension is your vector.
That is what you're storing.
If it is five 12 dimensional, five 12,
and how many 32, such five,
12 dimension tensor you are storing here, which is too huge.
And that is the problem. So what we do,
we reduce the BA means I don't have to store here much
or here, or here, here.
So this is this, this, this is, uh, this is just I,
we have done for the demo purpose.
But when you will actually process this one, uh, then, uh,
uh, keeping the eight will simply slow down your process.
So it's better to keep it little higher
for the very huge data set,
but then you need the better, uh,
machines also to process it.
So is equal to eight.
Just to avoid the om error,
which I was getting, if you'll not keep.
So yeah, that's all creating the batch.
Now, batch created using this data loader class.
This, we already know how to do that.
Now here, what we are left with the encoder decoder,
and then connection of the encoder decoder
to create a sequence to sequence model.
So we'll use as usual the tonn module.
So here we are creating one class
for the encoder plus first.
And then first thing is, the first thing is the constructor.
In the constructor, we are,
what we are doing is we are creating, uh, this, uh, uh, so
what I'm doing is I am creating, uh, I'll show you this, uh,
whatever you're seeing on the screen, this kind
of architecture where I'm feeding the input
to the embedding layer, and the embedding layer
output will go as an input to the SSTs.
Okay? This is how I'm creating Now in the encoder, in the,
in the encoder part,
this is the architecture which I'll create in the decoder
part, what will happen, I'll feed the input
as one hot will will go to the embedding layer.
Embedding layer output will go as an input to the Lian
Lium output will go as an
input to the fully connected layer.
Because at every time a stamp, I need the output and output.
You can only get using the fully connected layer,
what will be the dimension of the fully connected layer.
It'll be equivalent to the vocabulary size
of the Hindi corpus here.
Okay? So that is how the network I'm going to create.
I'll show you. So first of all,
I start with the embedding layer.
Okay? So embedding layer will have the input
as the cap size.
You see this to dissembling layer. What is the input?
Input is the, is a vector,
and vector dimension is the dimension of cap size.
Here, I had only four words in my vocabulary.
So each word is represented I four dimensions.
So, but it'll be cap size.
If it 10,000, it'll be 10,000, 20 2022. So on.
So that is the first thing to the embedding layer.
Now, embedding layer will give the output in some dimension,
depends on how many neurons
I'm using at the embedding layer.
So that will be the dimension from this embedding layer.
And then, uh, the input to this will be the padded, uh,
sequences that will be the input to this particular layer.
So these two are telling input and output dimension.
This is giving the, uh, input, the,
the padded di uh, padded input.
Okay? Now,
after this, once the embedding layer is done,
next layer is your LSTM as you can see here,
after the embedding layer is done.
Next layer is the LS tm. So LSTM here.
So what will be the input to the lstm,
the output from the embedding dimension.
So embedding embedded layer, whatever is the output,
and whatever is the dimension of vector.
Here, here, here, each time is stamp.
That will be the input to the LS tm.
So that's why input size to the LS TM is
the embedding di embedding dimension,
whatever it is, giving as an output.
And then, uh, hidden size.
Hidden size says that how many neurons I'm using inside each
of these LS TM cells.
So we call in the LS tm, inside the lstm,
we have the neural network, right?
That will act as input gate for GA gate or put gate.
So there are how many neurons I'm placing so
that I will decide here in the hidden dimension.
Okay? Batch first is just
to create your dataset, starting with the batch.
Then number of input, and then its dimension.
So this is what we have, okay?
This is what we have at the encoder party.
At the encoder party. I don't have any output,
which is going from each of this, uh, timestamp.
But there, there in the
decoder, you will see the difference.
After the lium, I'll keep the fully connected layer. Okay?
So yeah, so this is what the constructor, which will tell,
okay, what is the blueprint of my encoder architecture?
So this is what it is. Now,
I will actually create the forward pass.
In the forward pass. Very simple.
You call the embedding fun, uh, embedding
what you have already declared here, pass the x.
What is the XX in this particular case is one hot
vector, okay?
The input, and you get the embedded output,
which will be the output to the LSTM.
And LS. TM will give, you know, that three, two outputs,
but then, uh, three outputs.
In fact, the, uh, the output at each time is stem
and the, the final hidden state output
and the final Celeste output.
So this is how the LS TM gives you the output, right?
That means that this context vector,
where you'll have the two tensor
and one tensor will be the,
which is coming at each time stamp
of this lstm, which I don't want.
So I will not carry out, I will not use this output anymore.
I'll be utilizing this output
and this output for the decoder.
For the decoder, okay?
So yes, this is what we have the encoder.
This is what we have the encoder.
Later on, I can say, right? What is the embedded dimension?
What is the hidden dimension in?
Earlier I was keeping to 56.
Again, I just converted to 1 28
because I had to show you the remote.
So that's all. Then I have called the, created a class
for this encoder architecture in coder.
By feeding all these dimensions,
whatever I want means I'm just here is the class encoder.
Here is an object of this encoder in coder, okay?
By giving the dimensions.
So, uh, uh, sorry.
So first I have to run this, then this, then this,
and then this one, this will run.
Okay? So here you can see that, uh, what will happen.
This etch underscore n shape, CCO n shape, just to
show you that this whole pipeline is working.
Encoded pipeline is working.
It is, it is, it is printing the shape of my, uh, uh, the
s estate CT and hidden estate St at the final timestamp.
At the final timestamp. And what is, what,
what is its shape?
All those job matter.
Uh, any question,
Okay? And
I feel like we don't want that concept
of your money management and the concept
Of Fatima, what concept you don't
want, Okay?
Maybe. Alright, no problem.
So, uh, I was here, I was telling here,
so at the final time stamp, I will have the hidden state
and the cell estate.
You can recall the LST architecture, right?
So that is what I'm just extracting,
and it is working just to show you the output it is working.
So here, the batch size is one,
because I have not faded the complete batch here.
The eight is the, uh, uh, uh, I think,
uh, what is the eight?
Eight is batch. Oh, sorry, batch size is eight.
Eight is batch. Uh, eight is the batch size.
And uh, 1 28 is the dimension, which is coming out
of this hidden dimension.
Hidden dimension, okay?
And, uh, I believe this, uh, this is, uh,
it is single torch size is a single, uh, uh,
tensor, right?
Having the, for the eight different, uh, mass size.
And each of that, uh, is like 1 28 dimension
because here the L-S-T-M-I have kept 1 28, 1 28, 1 28 hidden
dimension with the neurons.
So the pipeline is working, okay?
So, uh, for the next step where this one is not required,
single, that is a single tensor not required.
So I have just skew squeezed it
because here you'll see that context vector.
What I want, that has to be fed to the decoder part, right?
So I just want two context vector means context vector.
Where, where will be the two tensors?
One will be the tate, one will be the ate that will go
to the celest in the Dakota.
So I have squeezed it. One is, uh, this one is eliminated.
If you will use this code, you can squeeze it.
So ba size, and here I mentioned you can keep it.
Okay, so now that is also done
and uh, you can actually print and see.
But that, okay, how does the context vector,
hidden state st will look like?
How does the cell state will look like?
It is nothing but a vector, like as you can see here, okay?
And they're different. They're not same
because hidden state is, is it's some part
of the cell state, right?
You can recall the output gate of the LST.
This is what we have in the encoder part of the LSTM.
Now it's time to build the decoder first,
and then we'll combine both of them
to create the sequence to sequence model.
So now in the decoder, what happens?
You see that most of the things would be same.
Okay, so let us start.
So here also we start with the one hot vector, okay?
It goes to the embedding layer, then there is Altium,
and then there is a fully connected network
which gives you the output.
So you can see here embedding layer, same way,
what we have done for the in coda, LSTM, okay?
Same way, what we have done there.
But after that I have one more layer called linear.
So in this linear layer input will be the hidden dimension,
whatever is the hidden dimension of the LST, okay?
And then output will be in the vocabulary size.
Now, that is what you have to remember
because any word can be the next word.
So your output will be always in the dimension of
what is the input dimension of this one hot vector.
If it's seven. So in the fully connected layer, you have
to keep seven neurons.
If it is 1 28, you have to keep 1 28.
And that's why it is a four cap size, okay?
That's all then forward, you can understand right forward,
uh, propagation for the decoder.
Now here we are calling embedding.
Here we are calling LS tm.
Here we are calling fully connected layer.
So again, we'll get the prediction at
Hidden Estate Solicitate.
Where here at the final timestamp, I'm talking,
you'll get the prediction at Hidden Estate and Solicitate.
And there is one more thing, the predictions,
predictions you will get at every timestamp.
So because prediction, I'm storing,
because that is what you have
to store to calculate the loss.
I said, right? So I'll store the, uh, prediction here,
then only I can calculate the loss with the correct label.
So predictions, you can see here,
I'm first calculating the prediction from each time stem,
and then I'm storing predictions also.
So these three things are being stored, call theod,
make it, uh, uh, what is that object.
Okay? And uh, now, uh,
this, uh, decoder output shape would be something like
that just for the check that, okay,
what will happen if the input will go
to the encoder you have already processed
and from output, how it'll come.
So you can see that the it'll the best
size, it'll still eight.
And this is the like dimension of each, uh, predictions.
So in the prediction, you have 24,514.
So that is the, uh, why it is 24,514.
I believe it should be similar to the vocab size,
what we have got earlier, okay?
Uh, where it was, where it was, let me just check that.
Uh, somewhere vocab size, yeah,
25, 20 4,514.
Those main neurons we have kept where here, 25,514 here,
also here also at East Timestamp,
these many neurons are being kept.
And hence we are getting the, those many predictions as a,
as a probability distribution
because there is a soft mix,
which we have applied at the output layer, okay?
That you have to remember. So yeah,
the pipeline is working now we just have
to create a wrapper.
A wrapper will create the encoder, create the decoder wrap
around it, give you the new class,
which has the implementation
of both the encoder and the decoder.
That is what it is doing. You can say
that it'll take the encoder, it'll take the decoder.
It'll also use the device.
Device in the sense the, the GPU, okay, for the training.
Then I'm just creating the forward propagation as usual.
So in the, in the forward propagation, what we do,
we first create the batch size, the target length,
the target vocabulary.
These are all the things which we already have already
available here.
Actual things are, start that first of all, uh,
how it'll run, it'll start with the encoder, okay?
Encoder, when it'll run, it'll give you two things.
Final here, the state final tate tens. Okay?
And that you have to, uh, unsqueeze and then it'll go.
Now see there is a loop in the decoder, there is a loop
because decoder will act like a next
word prediction task, right?
You have to take one, one word, uh, first word,
give the next word, then first two word, give the next word,
then first three word, then uh, next word, right?
So that is what is being applied here
in this particular case.
So once you will decode it line
by line, you will understand it.
Okay? So we are actually applying the teacher forcing in the
case of, uh, this one Dakota.
But here it is being applied based on some threshold, okay?
You can make it completely
or there is some method which is being implemented
here, right?
So you just, uh, you can decide, decide the teacher forcing
how you want to apply it.
Okay? So now, uh, uh,
so what does it mean if I'll explain quickly, right?
Uh, because it's already nine 10.
What does it mean that I am calling a random function?
It'll gimme one number, number between zero
and one means some, some 0.1, 0.2, 0.3.
Suppose I have already fixed the teacher forcing ratio is
like say, uh, uh, 50 suppose 0.5.
Point five. So if the random number is less than 0.5,
then only it'll apply the teacher forcing.
Otherwise for that time stamp, it'll not apply.
See, this is just a, some, some way
of applying the teacher forcing, okay?
You can make it compulsory also,
or you can make it some kind of random, uh,
sampling also in this that whether you want to apply or not,
but every time stem sometime you can apply.
Sometime you will notice so that you want your decoded
to learn better and better, okay?
Every time I don't give you the correct input,
you also learn sometime sometimes I not give you the correct
input and all those things, right?
So this is what is the sequence to sequence model.
Once you will learn this, uh, once you will, uh,
misc create this one, then you have to create, its uh,
what do you say, the object sequence
to sequence model before that.
You can push it to the GPU.
If you have a, it's available
last function optimizer criteria and optimizer, right?
You can set it a box set clip.
It is for exploding gradient problem, okay?
That, uh, I'll clip it if my gradient
will grow more than one.
Something like that. Not required, but it is used here.
So you can also use, so now
this is the training loop which we have been
developing for other models.
Also, there's a training loop.
First of all, you have to get the batch, okay?
Epoch in the range of epoch, what you have
to do is initially the epoch loss is zero source
target in the train loader.
Train loader had anyway created the batch.
You fetch one by one each batch source language,
target language, push it to the device optimizer.
First of all, gradient, make it zero. Call the forward pass.
And this model represents sequence to sequence model,
which already has the encoded decoder wrapped into it,
which we have seen that teacher forcing.
Here it is kept at 0.5.
You can, if you wish you to use, you can use it.
Otherwise you can make the code in such a way
that it'll compulsory reapply.
Now, uh, for the first time Ms stamp,
I don't want to predict anything.
Uh, why output dimension, uh, ignore SOS
because, uh, SOS is not a token which is being predicted
by the decoder, right?
It is like by default we are pushing.
So that's why this first line is required.
Rest, it will do the same thing
as I've said this whole, these two lines.
Actually it is doing the same thing at the quarter time.
It works like a, uh, self supervised data, okay?
And then calculating the loss, backward propagation,
everything being calculated, optimizer, total loss.
And I'll not run this one,
otherwise I'll show you that it'll take more time.
But I had run it for, uh, sorry, got run.
So I had to run everything else also. Mm.
Anyway, so uh, I think, uh,
it was available with all of you.
You can run this one random is not defined
why random is not defined.
Random, random where it was,
But how much time it took for you to run it.
Oh, 20 minutes took me for this setting.
It took me 35 to 40 minutes.
But this is small samples and uh,
and then all these things will run.
You can do it, you can just, uh,
before sleeping, you just keep it morning.
You will see that everything either
because it'll run, it'll not exceed the memory error
at least, okay?
It'll not terminate in
between if there's no internet connectivity error
because you're using the collab version.
So it'll run it. So
before sleeping, you can keep, you can put the,
what I believe I kept 50 aok, my loss started with 6,000,
it reduced up to 700, which is too huge, right?
So, but I saw that if you can keep 500 AK instead of 50
with this setting of data
and batch sizes, whatever I have shown you,
I guess it can go up to zero, 0.5 C.
Here it is starting at 9,300. That is the loss.
So machine translation task is actually difficult, okay?
So, uh, you can see that two issues.
So if you want to reduce it to zero, close to zero, you have
to run it for 500 to 1000 a block.
And then you will see the actual translation
is being done properly.
I tried with this version
and try not giving me the correct translation.
Like this is the inference time code where I have
to do the translation and I have asked, okay, for
how are you, what is the translation?
It has given me B, which is wrong.
Similarly, I have taken one sentence from my corpus,
it has given me wrong sentence.
So all these things, but what I will suggest to you, all
of you try it for thousand AK 500 OC just before sleeping.
You keep the laptop open for the day, okay?
And then you will see that the translation,
I guess the translation quality will be really better.
But this code itself will run
and it'll do all the things, everything it has, right?
So please do the practice.
It is now up to you how much, uh, practice you do as well as
with little bit of tweaking and all.
And obviously you need some GPUs to run it
with the entire dataset.
Remember, I have only taken the sample
of dataset 10,000 and this is the case.
I have told you only for 10,000 of the data.
But when you run with one lag, 77,000 data,
I mean it's difficult actually.
You need to have a good GPUs and could RAM put that way.
Okay? So yeah, this is what I have.
And finally, I was talking about the blues score.
I gave some clue also in the last
class, what is this blues score?
Actually it is comparing the final
Hindi sentence prediction.
What is given by the sequence to sequence model.
It is matching with the actual ground truth,
which is available in your corpus or not.
And because blue is blue score ranges, this one, okay?
Uh, if it is between zero 2.2, 2.3, then it is considered
as good, uh,
but better than 0.3, it is difficult
to achieve without attention model.
Those are all things, uh, we'll see
that one why it is difficult
and all when we talk about that engine.
Okay? So anyway, this is now available with you.
If you have any questions, you can ask me anywhere.
Uh, but it's more on your practice.
I've given you just a walkthrough that how,
how you can build it.
Yeah, code is a little longer, I understand,
but uh, this is how the sequence
to sequence model you can build
and even going further when you learn the transformer,
I mean you can imagine, right?
That is also encoded decode architecture,
but a lot of in between things.
Here I have only one LS TM and embedding layer.
There you have self attention.
Then you have many other things on top of that, right?
Everything we have to code, yeah.
So blue score at 0.57, is it uh, 57 percentage
or how the down
Three it has uh, 0.5, like you can see that, right?
Uh, blue score is in the range of zero to one
and uh, uh, like, uh, higher is better we say.
And it is, it is uh, it is a score between, it is not kind,
it is not a error where the lower is better error.
We always talk, talk in terms of lower is better, right?
But blue score is give, okay, your reference sentence
and your prediction how much they're matching it is kind
of a similarity.
Kind of a similarity, okay?
So it is not an error directly, uh,
but it is a, okay how two sequences are matching,
Okay? Yeah.
That's why hire is better in this particular case.
And below answer on the blue, blue skirt 0.57
because we ap are very less, that could be the reason,
uh, 0.57,
Uh, um, uh, that, that the, that's why, uh,
I think 0.578 has given in this particular case.
Okay? So for the, uh, for the training, what we have done,
so it is, it is, if it is, uh, if it is between zero
and 1.5, we will be treated as good.
Okay? Uh, okay between zero and one,
but blues score is sometimes misleading also sometimes, uh,
uh, so we have other mattresses also
for this one like Bert score, uh, we have some more kind
of similarity measures to compare the two.
Why? Because I have explained the other day blues score
between the two sentences.
Like Mara, it should be like Mara,
then it'll give blue score as one, right?
Mm-hmm. Exactly same.
Uh, in fact, if it is Mara
and Aja, I mean blue score will go down.
But in the English many times you are, are you going,
you are going, you are going has the two different meaning
re both are correct, but then blue
score doesn't consider that.
It always look for the what is my ground truth
and based on that it calculates that.
So it is sometimes not giving the correct
or uh, correct picture.
Okay? So yeah, but this is how it is being calculated.
Okay?
Okay. So I guess, uh, this will be a very good exercise
for all of you to just do the practice,
whatever it is written there, and then tweak a little bit
of code, right?
Because now you're going into the, the, the path of the
LMS language models.
This is what they do, right?
And they also started the transfer model
with the machine translation task itself.
And that's how these, all these breakthrough has come.
So you must do the practice, do the, uh, practice,
and then you will get lot of clarity
how these models are actually built.
Now, when you will have the clarity at this level,
then going to the LLM, seeing that what is there inside
and coding will not scare you at least
because it is just a stacking the multiple
things on top of each other.
That is what in the transformer they have done.
Obviously with some logic, not just a stacking,
like here we have done two layers of the LS tm,
three layers of the STM.
Obviously there is some logic, uh, behind,
but coding would not be, coding would not scare you See,
nowadays you don't have to code any of these things in,
in, in from the scratch.
Although I have shown you everything
from the scratch almost.
But then the next version available, this whole sequence
to sequence model is given
as a package call and get the output.
I mean those things are available,
but uh, having the internal understanding that
how it is built and all it is very much anyway,
we are going into the abstractions right now.
We are not coding forward propagation,
backward provocation optimizer, nothing.
Everything is abstract away.
Next version, we'll see even abstract way where we have the
for sequence to sequence modeling.
We have one single function call, get the translation.
But there you can't do the multiple tweaking.
The fine tuning. Fine tuning you can do,
but at the training time, you can't, uh, change play much
around with the network architecture.
It is fixed. Okay? So you'll see the pro and cons.
Any other questions? See
after today we have three more classes I guess
that is sufficient for this particular course.
So next class we'll have, we'll be on the Saturday,
we'll start with the attention architecture there.
Okay? And uh, same code.
I will also do with the attention
by adding the attention layer in
between everything would be same.
We'll add attention layer in between
after understanding the theory
and we'll see what is the difference it is making.
Okay? That will see in the next class.
And then after that we'll have two more classes.
We'll understand the attention in more detail.
We don't want to touch the transformer here Now
to not overload any way.
In the next course, LLM, you will start
with the transformer architecture.
Okay? So we are on track.
Yeah, sure, sir. Sure sir.
Thank you. Then let us meet on Saturday.
Yeah, thank you.